so
uh let's go over the sill
okay it's the
basics so we would be looking in the
same
direction
okay my palm goes on the back of his
hand my fingers will come around the
front you're going to have to get up and
move around
my fingers will come around and be able
to have turning power pulling power for
the twist okay ah move yourself so
you're
comfortable don't if you dip your elbow
back it's going to hurt
okay then this
knuckle of my
thumb
goes
on that part of his stumb
bone this
way like your book end pinky more
dominant than
index you're down on the hand not at all
on the wrist down on the
hand if you employ the second hand it's
down on the
fingers and you'll take this pinky
finger and curl it behind the other one
later here this
one couple things to never let
happen as as you're in the lock
proper never
lose the perpendicular angle to the
ground
no no never lose the verticality of the
elbow when you're in the lock proper so
don't let it dip down definitely do not
let it dip
back so you use
your internal and inertial engines to
keep that elbow in that position
okay so he tries to go forward no you'll
have your inertial engine try it slowly
so you don't hurt yourself so he can't
do it he tries to drop his elbow tries
to drop his elbow again you go and you
don't have your internal engines
traveling up the arm to stop
that the lock is like everything we do
here for example we just did Niko and
Niko's not in the
wrist so it looks like I'm trying to be
in the wrist but I'm
not I make contact here it goes up the
arm and it touches the
center it's the center move okay
do you understand all
right so we don't want any play in his
wrist whenever you do the internal
engines you take out the slack in the
wrist all the time okay and you can't do
that if you attack the
wrist so
no
no just like put a guys
you no one should be be able to stand
still and I move this around this is all
incorrect
okay
so some more it's it's a feeling it's
not that I'm cranking him and then
eventually I wind up his arm and get his
shoulders do you see that there's no
there's no
crank there's no crank right no so but
that's in his Center
do you
see so don't no you're actually losing
control and you're going to lose kazushi
cuz it's only going to be in his
shoulder another point is to put my
hands where I told you to put my hand
and to hold as I told you to hold your
palm will be flat on the back of his
hand
so you won't be like this do you see
that you won't have space
there and it is that lack of
space that is giving you your
adhesion okay just like any anywhere you
touch you're going to pay attention that
that Palm is ever so important not like
this so the same thing here see no space
this hand is helping me keep no
space you see okay Bo boom don't over
crust it this moves his
body okay all right so let's get the
Palm right and let go of trying to hurt
someone
go
so on her size hand
I can capture the
thumb with this do you
see and it looks like okay
cool on his size
hand for me to capture that thumb I
start to lose it and he's not that tall
you start getting taller people doesn't
work
okay so I
push right
there with this nothing
again
okay here like
this sometimes you'll go oh he can he
can grab
me grab
me hey because the internal aspect it it
has his so for
example
um yes do you see he's he he's off
balance right now do you feel that
Tristan okay so I don't
slowly take a step in a different
place do you see so this is what kazushi
is is that you have a center
okay and because you have a center even
though we're static he's actually not
mobile because I have his tandem okay
it's just you usually we we move the
tent okay but it's not because I moved
it that I
actually uh took his balance it's
because I had seized the tonden
initially okay got it okay so he can't
grab my hand like and drop his elbow he
can okay but to that internal engine
We'll add inertial engines make it even
more difficult for someone to drop the
elbow okay all right so I I feel like
doing so I wasn't okay I I will just do
it from from EO okay so I'm going to
come
in and here's where you have that same
Center seizure with this adhesion here
okay so um just slow slowly so you could
feel it and they could see it it looks
like we're just standing here and I'm
pinning him okay but I'm not I have a
Center again so if he tries to move
it'll you'll see it's making him fall do
you guys see that do you get it okay so
the kazushi is there it's important that
you use that and not this pin because
this I don't have you do do you feel
like I can pin him but he can get around
it get around it and don't have him okay
I would have to outow him so this is on
the
inside and just go one and move it
around and now you're exactly where you
were okay now I
trade control points from here to here
but it's going up his body moving his
Cent and then we have the same katama as
we always do just instead of here I'm
over
here
[Music]
same
kazushi into his
Center making him
[Music]
move
in
[Music]
CER
C
[Music]
relax all right
um the final kazushi pattern into the
pin is quite
unique and uh I'll try to explain what
I'm doing but basically it is a reverse
spiral uh of UK so is going to
lower
themselves uh or be lowered kind of
backwards from EO so EO takes them head
first and Sono is going to take them
feet feet first okay so uh I'll try to
try to explain it but it's going to do
it so first let me see if I can figure
out how to do it the other goofy way
okay so you'll be
here and you you see their body in in
what looks like EO and so you come to
the other side you see and then you go
head
first and you do
that I'll try it one more
time
Soom
boom and look at his orientation can you
guys move please okay okay you're going
here you go one and then you get out of
the way and you lay them down here
okay just like in our EO we don't
actually take that angle that EO for
that angle would be you're going here
EAS see you're going
straight get
up okay don't let me push that
down
okay or move with me when I move
forward and I can't take it down he just
keeps moving
forward in our e he goes around me
remember he goes this way
Bo so likewise in in the incorrect song
fi when you come here
and you go this way and I'm going to try
to push this down don't let me and
you're not going to be able to do it and
he can keep moving with you if he's not
strong enough just keep moving it's not
going to
happen so what I do
instead is a same time spiraling
action but it's backwards
so I start to move him we going to slow
down lighten up
on I'm moving him
backward and I'm going to kick his feet
out with a cooku projection into his
Center
here so we come
around and this goes
who into
center it's less pronounced like
everything is in suar waza but in Tachi
waza he should go
flying
okay but you can see that that pattern
is very
different
[Music]
okay between the internal engines and
the inertial engines the uh external
engines don't have to violate Marshall
principle Okay so as I
go uh here and I don't want to reach up
like this there's no need so I'm moving
his
Center okay no need to reach up it is a
redundant control of the arm at the
elbow okay so I lower the
hand
to where I can keep my elbow anchored
don't reach
up